Jason we hear that YouTube either is
currently doing this or will be planning
this paid subscription fee do you plan
to be a part of it and what are your
thoughts on that I you know I I don't
want to do that i I don't know i don't
want people i don't want there to be a
step people have to take before they
watch my videos you know when i hear
youtube I you know I think of a lot of
the you is like you get to just watch
this video not it's not I don't think of
YouTube is me I think of YouTube as the
audience and and sometimes I'm the
audience and sometimes I'm not the
audience but I feel like I don't want
there to be us I want it I want people
to be able to watch it as easy as
possible as quickly as possible and as
much as possible and that step of you
know a lot of the audience are you know
whatever they're like 12 whatever 313
I'll say 14 you know for them to be like
you know would be like well Don I on a
month they still have to get their life
parents permission to make that step and
the parents are like well why are you I
don't feel comfortable that which is
totally understandable what you know
what you're doing is you're just putting
a like a step and a roadblock before
people to getting to see what you do now
granted there are some people that you
know that are so popular that you know
maybe if I was them and and if for me I
think it was kind of worth it and the
price was low enough maybe i would but
for me right now I don't know I've just
been very kind of I perform for free
every single week so money is not you
know getting as much money as possible
out of someone isn't my goal it's having
the biggest audience possible and the
rest of that will come you know whether
it's like branding stuff for other
opportunities but I don't want I don't
want some 30 year old kid that the but
you know bothers parents to give me a
dollar ninety-nine a month and whatever
I get of that to watch my videos that's
what the ads are there for that tried to
sit through all those annoying ads right
well I mean we've seen it with Twitter
and Facebook and even netflix where they
increase certain things and then there's
this resistance on the part of the
audience because they are used to
getting stuff for free yeah but then you
see somebody like a Marc Maron who has
some of his shows that their premium
show you pay for so do you think that
somehow creates value there's always a
market losses a notion you want to
create value sure I mean I think you
know if you say I'm teaching something
that's teaching a free improv workshop
people might be like well you know it's
free like I'll go if I don't but if
somebody's like you know there's a pay
you know you mean like you you feel like
there is a there's a value that they're
charging that for a reason so it's that
it's that appearance you know the thing
is people can't I mean there used to be
like there was a pre-roll ad in a
YouTube video um people were like I'm
not watching this and then everyone
started doing it and then it just became
you know I'm sure like in television
like I don't know when commercials
started coming into it but i'm sure some
ways like I don't want to my I want
anything to be interrupted now when the
commercial comes on I mean annoying as
it is you know you're not like what is
this what am i watching it's just like a
stop sign you know when you're going
down a street it's part of what it is so
if it if it can't win across the board
then it's an across-the-board thing but
for me I don't I don't want to slow
anything down for me I just want the
biggest audience possible
you